welcome to this video round 12 of the
candidates tournament and this is the
game of them tournament leader and heavy
favorite to qualify for the desired spot
to challenge magnus carlsen x-bow
champion vishy anand playing right
against Dimitri and Drake in playing
black yeah how's the situation before
the game honored is cruising with plus
free nicely leading the tournament and
Drake in His on minus one if i'm not
mistaken so he has very little chances
to to do anything um for honor this is a
game that he absolutely shouldn't lose
it would be brilliant to win and the
draw a certainty perfectly okay so he
said i guess in a mood like try a little
bit but don't do it without but don't do
it with taking too much risks let's see
what what happens in the game I'd reckon
playing the caro-kann this son I need to
think about that and he played it before
in the event hmm I'm not sure actually
it is part of his repertoire it's not
like a huge surprise but he had played
mostly the sicilian before yeah be she
is playing Knight c3 he's one of the
players that is still regularly going
for this classical approach nowadays the
the exchange sorry the advanced
variation of course body five is
absolutely the main line of the
caro-kann and of course Anand has played
a lot of games with that with various
lines the short variation with nida
three and nights III and everything but
he always had Knight c3 in his
repertoire the classical way to play and
it's of course not a not a bad way to
play quite often you can you will find
that lines that are named the classical
something there is quite a lot classical
stuff a classical Sicilian the classical
Slav the classical whatever
these are pretty much ever green lines
that you can always play and they have
some some life some life to it some
ideas to it so it's good to be a to be
playing the classics sometimes okay so
we have the Bishop f5 line the main line
and here in this position black has a
choice there is the absolute main move
of 97 here widely accepted as some as
the most precise actually after which
this is the normal continuation and
dragging played it differently though he
played the movie 6 yeah this is an
interesting line that I have analyzed
myself some time ago the idea is that
black is not willing to put the night on
d7 yet but he wants to if possible put
the knight on c6 the idea is that if
white now continuous as he does in the
main line something like that black can
actually play c5 and a quick Knight to
c6 and this is immediately giving him
very satisfactory play I've got a very
sound structure the light squared Bishop
this is gone it's just very nice um it's
not like it's completely without any any
problems or whatever but it's it's very
ok for black this move order however has
a disadvantage and this is what are not
displaying 95 pushing the bishop bag and
now Bishop d3 yeah here's a little trap
of course black cannot capture on d4
after night xf7 he is losing instantly
so black basically has to take on the
three Queen takes now 97 yeah enter here
we see the big difference to other
lights white gets in the move f4 yeah
and this is some just my opinion a
pretty nice structure for white he's got
this
not only five which is just a very very
annoying piece to two keepers black and
I mean it's always annoying what I'm
trying to say is for black to face this
piece only five and you basically cannot
really take it ever as it is so nicely
supported by the pawns white is just a
nice advantage in space yeah well he
played yet to check Iran before which is
the normal way to proceed it has some
two ideas one ideas that exchanges
should help black and defending so move
like Bishop t2 is sometimes played but
the exchange is something that probably
black welcomes as he has little space
for his pieces and getting one pair of
pieces are probably okay c3 played by a
lot Bishop e7 back and now Bishop t2
simply keeping more pieces on the board
Knight f6 long castles by the way um
this here is not to be recommended it's
simply a bit too risky to capture this
um one simple thing is that after y
takes here you need to take with the
king which looks entirely ridiculous so
nothing that black wants to try Knight
f6 as mentioned long castles and short
castle yeah and this in fact is a
position that we had in the world
championship match between anand and
carlsen an aunt was playing white cards
and black he's surprisingly had played
the calc on and him in this position and
played the move Knight d4 in the world
championship match and and Reagan was
playing right into that so it's
basically asking on an okay you had this
in your match what exactly have you
prepared now this was played as
mentioned in the match and after all
this cards and had a pretty good
position with the good equalizing
chances they had effect relatively
quickly agree to draw after the Queen
trade um
Alan's mafia was indeed much stronger i
played Queen to f3 which had been played
before even years ago and it keeps more
pieces on the board simply Quincy seven
and now c 4 which is also a good move to
play grabbing space controlling d5
possibly allowing the bishop to come to
t3 black played a 5 yeah this is a
typical move and the structure to gain
some space on the queenside we see that
after the King wolffian Brooke t8 Bishop
c1 prophylactic moves like even pushes a
4 and this has been played before
exactly that if for however is a new
move um there was a game between two
pallav and the strong russian grandma
selects a drea a great expert in the
crack on with the rook f2e eight in the
new delhi the theorem on tier on how do
you how do you actually pronounce that
tier on the capital of Iran and I don't
really know um well it was the world
championship two thousand and arm
topalov got a pretty quick and dangerous
attack with 92 and this g45 move in
general this is the the main problem
that black faces in this structure this
is g45 pawn roller and it's not so easy
to get a direct counter play going and
I'm not really sure and rake it smooth
was maybe a maybe a bit more more active
but still I I must admit that I don't
like like exposition at all when I had
to look at this years ago I liked those
ideas with a quick c5 and Knight to c6
but this type of position I always
disliked this black simply because I
mean I'm not playing if you look at my
again I don't not playing against those
top level GM some playing against a wide
range of
opponents and I always pictured myself
sitting there's black ass against
someone was maybe a rated like 200
points lower so still good players but
players that I should somehow score
against and white has already made plan
you just move your night somewhere and
then you push g45 and you get an attack
pretty much automatic attack and assumed
they didn't like this prospect as
absolutely even someone with very low
level of her chest understanding can
fight this plan so why it's plan is very
much apparent while it's not so clear to
me what black is doing in fact the g4 g5
push did materialize in this game but it
always felt very annoying to me and yeah
I never liked blacks position much so it
feels a bit difficult for me to really
advise how black should should play yeah
well a 3 is what and raking played
provoking be three and now Bishop to b4
so we pushed the pawn all the way to a
three to provoke some weaknesses in fact
the White King is slightly Lucia there's
no doubt about it is paid c4 and b3
while black has a pretty compact upon
shield in the head of the King this is
quite quite safe okay but we see that
after rookie 3 now on draken plate very
in a very direct manner and I think this
is probably a mistimed but very
difficult he played now c5 and this
seems to already give white a pretty
decent position at least with the push
d5 yeah this is quite apparent what else
is there he right needs to push the deep
on it seems that by the way that he may
probably should have waited to bit
longer with pookie aid but I cannot
really tell if this is great I mean
should you really just always stay as
black and don't do much I mean I play
rook here 92 ng forint I really don't
see what black is doing against that he
probably needs to time the c5 move
want a better but yeah I don't know i I
don't I don't really I'm not an expert
on this opening I feel a bit overwhelmed
to suggest something what he did c5 led
to travel this is clear on apush d 585
and now just cd5 here in this position
in fact the autumn that we capture is
automatic and Anna took like four
seconds for it but here in fact the
computer points out an interesting move
which pretty much shocked me as cd5
looks completely normal and it's not a
bad move but the computer is suggesting
Knight to f5 giving white a pretty good
position and it's quite remarkable that
this seems to be true um at first you
look you think this is solely ridiculous
why not d for now giving me a protected
passer yeah but white is just replying
rupee to just quite simple and how is
black defending now against g4 and g5
the computer already gives white a
substantial advantage and I must agree I
mean this is a very very dangerous
attack it looks completely crazy to
allow the structure I mean it's somewhat
unrelated to other things happening why
why is this should work but the night on
f5 is just so strong it's a it's very
very difficult to play this position
even as black if you give the computer
sometime it gets too enormous enormous
advantages like more than one of a pawn
so probably d4 isn't isn't the real
defense yeah maybe black can take but
even that it's very very dangerous for
for black the simpler recapture for
example can lead to lots of problems
there's still g45 there is something
coming to a7 even rupee seven might be
in libya move now well what happens if
Black Voices plays b5 very directly now
I can also just take the pawn iam
and the computer is giving white a big
advantage probably based on this night
alone but it's not a very human will
move to play i just want to point it out
that sometimes things that look
completely normal like see txt 5 can be
improved upon yeah Knight b6 looks
normal and white cavity 5 it was
attacked three times yeah and here in
this position I believe that under akin
place he makes them makes a mistake and
that's the move Queen to c8 it seems
that here white men white has an obvious
at da wants to push these things and it
seems that black has to prevent that in
this position by simply taking on d5
it's not a happy move to play probably
because you don't want to give up the
two nights but this year is probably
what what needed to be done and it leads
to a position where I think that white
is somewhat better but it's certainly a
playable position for black let's see
here and look do you want this is the
point really you need this counter play
on the on the first rank sometimes
there's look g1 attacking this pawn or
you can at the moment you you threaten
he even and yeah well you can maybe
sometimes activate the Queen why a d8
taking here and so on it's a position
which is probably somewhere between
being somewhat better for white and
black having enough counter play but we
are not talking about yeah well you
could do that you could do that you must
take it really sd-6 is such a big threat
and this is what and raking ignored in
the game you played Quincy eight and
this you push the six and here we are
already in territory that is a very very
favorable for white maybe I'm I think
where we are we are in areas where if
you give this position the white
position to machine it will simply call
you because the play
gets enormously technical quite quickly
and this is due to the fact that white
has enormous offensive offensive active
potential night on e five possibilities
for these night jumps the deep one he's
got every piece and play get towards the
center and the King side but on the
other hand white has somewhat somewhat
open King that sometimes give count
gives counter blame yeah and reckon now
played the move rook to e8 which is not
the best defense according to chronic to
a computer but it's I think it's a
perfectly normal human move what what
should you do computer give c4 as the
tougher defense but I don't really see
it to be honest after white taking you
didn't really a newly gained much you
can play Bishop c5 for example getting
the bishop in tune into play but white
can if everything else fails i'm going
to play 94 and still have this option
left black is probably going to take
look here and i'm dropping back I just I
just haven't have a pawn extra and I'm
going to play this happen which is
almost impossible to prevent it's not
really a better defense than will create
so rupee 8 and now I'm yeah there are
there's more than one good move but uh
none played the best move really night
to h5 this is the most aggressive and
forcing move yeah now rookie 6 plate
other defenses are not really better for
example if you take and you are now
faced with this threat something like we
need 6d 787 rock t6 is fairly
embarrassing trapping the Queen ok I can
put this on the board sorry
Oh No sup man my notes are very
confusing confusing for myself but was
it Queenie six here okay Queenie six
year you can also look at their white
can play d7 and after takes takes white
can even take here and play the funny
move f5 and gets it absolutely deadly
attack the queen is attacked and if it
covers the rook it should cover the rook
there's f6 coming something like this is
simply disastrous at some s sister I'm
just a great attack yeah it at the end
unbreaking played rookie six it's as
good as any defense yeah here wishing
now took on f6 which is Chan which keeps
a winning advantage this is clear but
here I mean this is clear sir and I
sentence to say it's clear from the
further cause of the game if you analyze
it it's not like completely a parent or
anything and however in this position he
had a direct knock out which probably
would have prompted and Drake into his
sign in a couple of moves he could have
played the move d7 and this is
completely decisive we can look at some
lines very easy as this for example
check just winning a piece with no
compensation counterplay what's ever
like cannot take with that if you take
with the night I mean the other night
wyd is going to play Queen 2g form yeah
this is I think rather parent so I
always need to have an idea why it
wasn't played this is what I'm trying to
try to find out here Queen a queen g3
is also good I had Queen g3 in my in my
analysis I believe let me let me check
I'm doing most of it out of my head but
sometimes I need to check it yeah this
is what I was analyzing and now g6 there
is no other move and now f5 and this is
basically a deciding immediately black
must take there's nothing else and here
white has a choice he can play the the
computer move rock d6 threatening rook
g6 which is like completely over plus 20
or something or you can play the human
move which is easy to calculate just
take here and can't regain the material
being a an exchange up and a completely
winning position this is in fact quite
easy so after the seven it was
relatively clear I believe that black
cannot take with both pieces so the
Queen must move yeah well v7a be a tour
c7 doesn't make much of a difference for
the lines yeah this and now there is a
very strong that maybe are not
overlooked maybe I'm just speculating
there is more than one good move
actually but there is one complete
killer move this is f5 here and the
point is that after rook takes there is
Knight f6 check takes bishop age 6 and
this pawn is completely tying up or
moves all pieces up and white is now
just winning here on the King side
completely over this is even a maid
forced made an 8 or something going to
get this mate coming up it's a complete
complete disaster if black takes with
the Queen this is rook III and the queen
is trapped this kind of moves already
tough to see in advance um by the way if
you don't see rookie three you can also
just take here
and yeah not Queen f5 better keep better
do that and now any normal move like
that is just winning the game you are an
exchange up and you have the deadly d7
pawn who I'm sorry so on this was a
complete killer d7 it's not super
difficult to find those stuff but the
thing is if you look at this as as a
white player it's pretty clear you know
that you're winning the game now you
know that there is a win and you
calculate lines and you see a line that
you believe that wins you can of course
invest even more time and try to find a
line that is even more winning but you
need to move at some stage so I guess
aunt had calculated what he had seen and
thought okay this is winning and he's
right with that it's just not so
directly winning he took rook takes and
d7 quite comparable of course but it's
not that deadly win here and Queen cheap
queen g4 this is probably what he had
seen the ideas the the rook lived to g3
going form and made on g7 yet and dragon
defended in the best possible manner he
pushed c4 rook to e3 g6 and h 5 yeah it
looks it looks overwhelming doesn't it
yeah and in fact it is like now took
rook takes 90 for the absolute only way
to get at least some kind of code to
play with 93 and simply the the best
possible defense that could have been
could have been played ya know Anna took
on g6 like must recapture and now he
simply took the bishop so he was
accepting this this sacrifice and
allowed the Knight c3 a check which was
blacks counterplay IDM so this was also
completely fine
King situ yeah and now the simple Linus
if black just takes you which is losing
instantly and and and also easily this
is the main point why just place this
coming here and now why takes here and
this means that white is winning very
easily with Queen to d5 this rook c8 and
black does not really have any counter
play whites king it's looking a bit airy
but there is no real attack so this
wasn't the defense that Andre can could
seriously consider he played a b5 which
is by far the best practical chance in
this position this is quite clear King
bee three played again very good move by
anand and all night a form yeah and in
this position I believe Anand could have
played better he had 12 minutes on the
clock in this obviously complicated
position but ok white is a piece up
don't forget that why does a piece up um
and I think he had a move that could
could end the game again with bishop to
d2 this is probably winning but the
point is you can so easily say oh this
is winning okay but you still need to
calculate the lines with a couple of
minutes on the clock if you consider
that a 95 check I'm just going to show
you what kind of tricks there are King
takes em of course this was the idea
Queen air five check check only move and
now rotate yeah last-ditch attempt for
counter play so um what should why do
now it's not so clear-cut look at this
this is a big threat and can you defend
against that actually now you can but or
you can by the way let's do it this way
this is this is even a bit tough on the
brook should be a still be on da to
block it yeah here white only has one
move a 4 which is probably what you can
see beforehand it's not rocket science
but look at this
I'm going to take this Queen City King
Seto okay mean must be played yeah going
here I don't know if you want to want to
face this idea just just to show what's
in the position King situ and now i'm
black and even give another check check
need to go here and yes yeah well you
need to calculate this beforehand and
judge that this is not decisive in fact
white can defend with exactly this set
up and will win but it's not completely
trivial to calculate on seven or eight
moves beforehand this is always there's
always some trickery going on so Anna
didn't go for Bishop t2 it seems to win
outright really black has no one not
much more than what i just showed to you
he played the move Queen to f3 which
looks also perfectly logical covering c3
this counter play square getting the
Queen involved and it also going for
Queen d5 if possible it also controls a
eight this also useful so very young
understand the luminous and it in fact
it keeps a winning position I'm not
saying that it is is bad or anything but
Bishop to was a bit clearer yeah no one
dragon 1095 check of course island like
King c2 there is nothing else check the
check again went to be three check check
again I went to see to check 94 so now
we have the position two times but what
Anna did was of course a very
professional decision he repeated the
position two times and now be on move 41
so the time trouble was over and now on
and could take some time to decide how
to proceed obviously a very very
critical moment as
he can play King b3 and it's an instant
draw because of repetition of moves and
he basically had the chance to now play
a move and continue or take the draw if
you consider the tournament situation a
draw is perfectly all right as he is
leading the tournament very comfortably
and basically three three draws means
he's on he's got the qualification in
the back so the draw is perfectly okay
however if he would win the game it's
almost I mean let's say with the draw
he's like eighty percent qualified with
the win it's like ninety-nine percent
almost then then he would almost need to
lose the remaining two games which seems
pretty pretty a strange idea so he very
much likes to win the game of course um
after quite a long thing are not in fact
played King be three to get the draw so
a disappointing Wade somewhat to to end
the game and nevertheless how to look at
how to assess the position it's very
easy to claim that he should have played
on it's really easy to do so because
well nowadays you have those those
computer things and they will tell you
why this totally winning in this
position but it is a completely
different thing to actually calculate
and play this some especially
considering the the tournament situation
and absolutely certain if we would be in
in the first round of the tournament or
any other tournament where the situation
is somewhat less promising with the draw
he would have maybe invested even more
time and try to find a win because it's
it's melts like there is a win for white
very clearly but it's not it's not
completely easy of course i'm going to
show you now how white could have won
the game but
it's a it's far from far from trivial
let's start first with the human way to
play and this might win but it's not
completely easy this is will be king
need to go in to do six check 93 by the
way here the move knocking see two
masters make sent it can even go here
actually at least this is what the
computer is telling me but what kind of
line is that yeah it might be willing
but i'll show you a human line yeah what
what really was certainly am conceding
check Queen d2 the chacha 923 to block
the check and cover the rook and then
something like that look to f7 let's say
King e1 and the caption we have a
position where white is still a piss-up
but look at the position it's not easy
to assess you cannot move the night at
the moment as the rookie singing you
what exactly is why it's move there is
93 in the mix let's say I don't know
what kind of move should I play computer
gives rookie to where's the best move
just to show you what kind of crazy
stuff the computer would come up with if
I take it here for example I'm going to
jump IAM rock here mommy I check and now
here let's use pressure on d3 whites
position is not coordinated really you
shouldn't underestimate that why does
some in some of some of us strange spot
IAM the pieces are somewhat tied
together the rook to the night there's
huge pressure on the deform and this
night is always ready to join in
this is a computer that this is a
position that the computer is giving
plus two and says who I'm winning no
problem but play this and assess this
before and it's very tricky to do very
tricky to do I think island in the press
conference was said okay I know he's got
me I've got my map is up but he's got
two rooks and the Queen still there all
active and there's a night starting to
jump around and he couldn't assess it
quite quite reliably so I said okay a
draw is perfectly fine for my tournament
situation now we go to the area of
completely in human chess what is
exactly the win here and the winners
Roxy form this is the the direct win
which like completely kills black but
it's not like it's totally apparent this
move okay black takes what else and now
there are two moves winning but they are
both not very trivial Bishop e3 is the
worse the first one the intention is
Bishop to e7 white is not playing an
exchange down but he's got of Cain of
course the poor near the Bishop e7 is a
very substance substantial threat Queen
B 6 is the toughest defense and tending
Quinby to checkmate if the bishop moves
um and then the best is the Queen check
check King moves and Queen takes and
this is this seems to be a win form for
white but this is far from trivial again
black can for instance give this check
hack yeah and what are you going to do
now you're going to play rookie too yeah
maybe maybe this is even winning maybe
this is even winning but I can take here
yeah it's still not so easy to assess
the cleanest wind or quickest win from a
computer perspective is actually Knight
to g4 and this leads to some completely
crazy lines I can show you one of them
look to d6 and now the killer move is
queenie form look do you one check check
on g6 yes tags check check and sorry
it's here interior white has under move
that is completely unhuman h f 5 + f5
completely it if you give it to a
machine that will jump 2 + 20 or so
after a while which looks totally crazy
but it's really the case white threatens
Knight f6 with a devastating attack and
black has absolutely no defense to that
it's a it's really it's really crazy for
example look do six chat check king of
seven and now just wish away three yeah
and that's there's no defense check
check check why does mopping up the rest
of the position it's of course entirely
impossible to to to calculate anything
like that I mean we're still talking
about about the real people here no one
is going to calculate the caption here
and then I g4 I mean maybe but right
here you're simply out of it you're
never going to think of of Queenie four
and a five I mean this is completely
crazy what I in fact believe on a very
good day and with the complete
determination to in a must-win situation
that put it like that I think maybe
Arnaud can can do that this is feels
pretty realistic to me at least but I
entirely understand the rationale behind
that you're leading the tournament a
loss that can easily happen if you
bungle up the calculation of this this
complicated stuff and loss is fatal
while a draw is perfect
almost let's say the wind is perfect but
the draw is like ninety percent um so am
a very understandable decision to to
wrap the game up with the draw it bit
disappointing it would have been
fantastically fantastic achievement if
he would have would have wanted actually
he played an excellent game up to that
point it's still one of the best games
that are none played in this in this
event really really a great attacking
performance but yeah unfortunately he
didn't manage also don't forget the
black player in this game it's a it's
all about white but I mean it's it's 2-2
after this I mean you know that you're
on the ropes in this type of position
here d7 and it's all like coming down to
you like like an avalanche of an attack
and he put up the the best possible
resistance and was awarded with the draw
um in fact under 18 is not playing a
really bad tournament I mean he is on
paper one of the outsiders and he's
doing quite a ride with the minus one
score at the moment so to sum it up
which is still in excellent shape too to
qualify he missed the Chancellor but
it's not like it was some like a clear
could win or whatever it was a very very
complicated position that that I'm sorry
that wasn't like an easy win or anything
okay I hope you enjoyed the game it was
very interesting one thanks for watching